Harry Kersh: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Burger King in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
In the UK, we have three drink sizes.
We have a small,
which is 250 milliliters.
Joe Avella: This is a US small.
Harry: We have a regular,
which is 400 milliliters.
Joe: This is a US medium.
Harry: And we have a large.
Joe: And here [groans]
is a US large.
Burger King.
Harry: Now, in the UK, we
have three sizes of fries,
small, regular, and large.
Joe: Here's a Burger King small fry.
Here's a Burger King medium fry.
And a Burger King large fry.
Harry: So, of the three sizes
of fries that we were given,
I'm actually not sure
which one is the regular
and which one is the small,
because these two kinda look identical.
We're going to weigh them all.
We're gonna start with this
orange-bottomed bag.
80...
88 grams.
Now we're gonna weigh the
slightly darker orange bag
and see which size this is.
So, there's only a 5-gram difference,
but this one is the small.
So, a large fries in the UK
looks like it's around 180 grams,
which is double the regular.
[beep] I broke the scale.
[laughs]
We're actually having some concerns about
the sizes of the fries in the UK,
because our measurements showed
that the lighter orange bag
actually contains more fries
than the darker orange bag.
However, when lined up very
scientifically like this,
what we'll actually see is that
the bag sizes go up in
that color order instead.
So I think what's happened here is that
our small was actually
bigger than our regular.
Joe: Wow, a lot of fry
drama over there in the UK.
As you can see from our
sizes, it's pretty obvious
what the small, medium, and large is,
but, of course, we're
still gonna weigh them.
So let's start with the small fry.
Yep.
Boom.
Rogue fry.
And now the medium fry.
You're making a face.
I don't like that face.
It's like...
yeah, it's pretty similar.
I know how we will solve this, but not...
not that way.
Over here. Burger King
is in the hot seat, baby!
Burger King's in the hot seat!
Large fries.
So, I'm gonna do something
really tedious and boring.
Two, three, four,
12, 13,
20, 21, 22....
35 regulars,
10 kind of broken-up ones.
One, two....
34 and 18, but then a lot of smaller ones.
Producer: Arguably more than the medium.
Joe: Whoa!
That's pretty cold, Burger King.
That is pretty cold.
Don't act like you're surprised by this.
And I know what they're gonna
say. They're gonna be like,
"Well, everyone who scoops is different."
OK, but our scooper here
and their scooper in the UK
made a similar error.
Hmm.
Suspicious, right?
Frygate 2020!
Harry: So, this is a Whopper in the UK.
No, it's not, that's a Halloumi King.
Is this the Whopper?
Have they forgotten the f---ing Whoppers?
Burger King!
So, what we're going to
do is weigh a Whopper
and see how much a
Whopper weighs in the UK.
[burger thuds]
Joe: All right, let's take
a look at the US Whopper.
First thing I'm gonna
do, I'm gonna weigh it.
Oh, yeah.
That's a Whopper.
Booyah.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
gotta be scientific about it.
Harry: In the UK, you
can get Burger King's
chicken fries in three sizes.
A six-piece box,
a nine-piece box,
or if you're really hungry,
a 20-piece box.
Joe: In the US, according
to the Burger King website,
they have three sizes of chicken fries.
We went to, like, five Burger Kings.
Two.
And both of them said that
they only have one size,
the nine-piece chicken fries.
I don't know why that is.
And after
Burger King Frygate 2020,
I'm gonna count these.
There's nine.
Harry: So, what about calories?
Well, for example, a large Whopper meal,
the Whopper itself is 627 calories,
a 180-gram serving of large fries
would be 437 calories,
and a large Coke would be 209 calories.
That brings the total of a
large Whopper meal in the UK
to 1,273 calories.
Joe: And in the US Burger King,
the Whopper meal comes in at a hefty
1,600 calories.
That is an increase of about 378 calories,
or roughly 30%.
However, there are ways to
bring the calorie count down.
For example, if you get
the Whopper without mayo,
you save yourself about 157 calories,
taking the Whopper down to, like, 503.
The drink is a major culprit.
If you get a sugar-free
soda like a Diet Coke,
you immediately save
yourself 510 calories.
So with these minor adjustments,
you can get a large Whopper
meal for about 933 calories.
Harry: Now, for whatever reason,
the mayo in the UK only
comes to 6 calories.
So I'm not sure what you guys
are putting in your mayo.
Now, in the UK, a bacon
double cheeseburger
comes in at 430 calories.
Joe: And our bacon double
cheeseburger in the US
only has 404 calories.
Now, this has to be a "Food Wars" first,
where something in the
US has less calories
than something in the UK.
I do wanna point out,
our bacon double cheeseburger
does not come with mayo,
so I think that might
be the calorie culprit.
Harry: So we finally found
something that's less calorific
in the US than the UK.
Congrats, guys.
Joe: Error 404, mayo not found.
That's funny. Like, just
put that on the screen there
like an error code.
Harry: Here are some things
that you can only get
at a UK Burger King.
So, here we have the veggie bean burger,
which, you get these
two fried bean patties
with some lettuce, some
mayo, and some cheese.
Here we have the Halloumi King,
which is kind of exciting.
It comes with lettuce,
mayo, onions, tomato,
and then these two fried
pieces of halloumi.
They also offer that with bacon,
which seems slightly counterproductive
if you're a vegetarian,
but pretty delicious if you're not.
Joe: Hey, Siri?
[Siri beeps]
What is halloumi?
Siri: "Halloumi or haloumi is a semi-hard,
unripened, brined cheese
made from a mixture
of goat's and sheep's milk,
and sometimes also cow's milk."
Do you want me to keep reading? [beeps]
Joe: Yes.
Siri: [beeps] "It has a high melting point
and so can easily be fried or grilled.
This property makes it a
popular meat substitute.
Rennet is used to curdle the
milk in halloumi production,
although no acid-producing bacteria
are used in its preparation."
Joe: Huh, thanks.
I don't want that.
Harry: In the back here, we have a
Chicken Royale with bacon,
which is a longer chicken
patty that's fried.
Comes with lettuce, bacon,
and cheese and mayo.
To round out the burgers,
we have the Bacon King,
which is kind of like a larger version
of the bacon double cheeseburger,
but it also has mayo on it.
And then finally
available to us right now,
we have the jalapeño chicken fries,
which are kinda like their
standard chicken fries,
but with a spicy jalapeño coating.
Joe: I'm furious we don't have those.
That is ridiculous.
How did they have the jalapeño
chicken fries and we don't?
That is ridiculous.
Harry: So, on top of what
I've got in front of me,
there are also a lot of exclusives
that we have in the UK,
which I'll read for you now.
The steakhouse Angus, classic cheese melt,
a barbecue double melt,
a chili cheese melt,
the Roadhouse Crispy Chicken sandwich,
the Crispy Bacon King, a Rebel Whopper,
mac 'n' cheese bites, chili cheese bites,
apple slices, a Breakfast King,
a range of breakfast sandwiches
including a bacon butty
and a sausage butty,
porridge, and an Oreo Fusion,
which is like an ice cream
with some Oreos in it.
It has to be said that Burger King
isn't the friendliest
place for vegetarians.
They have some kind of vegetarian options,
like the Halloumi King
or the Rebel Whopper,
but unfortunately these
are actually cooked
in the same oil and on the
same grills as the meat.
So it's not 100% vegetarian.
Joe: Here is everything that is exclusive
to the Burger King in the United States.
I'm just gonna start here.
Impossible Whopper.
Even when we're trying to be healthy,
we still managed to figure
out a way to be unhealthy.
There's stuff in our Impossible meat
that has not been approved in the UK yet.
Crispy taco, here in Burger King USA only.
I don't know why there's
tacos at Burger King.
I don't know who's getting
a taco at Burger King.
That's ridiculous.
Crispy.
The Stacker.
Ooh, bacon.
The Double Stacker.
These things are so heavy.
This is so much.
Now, from my understanding,
what separates the Stacker
from the bacon double cheeseburger
is these are quarter-pound patties,
and also there's some sort
of Stacker sauce on here.
Special Stacker sauce.
Spicy crispy chicken sandwich.
The barbecue bacon
crispy chicken sandwich.
Spicy chicken sandwich junior.
For the little guys!
You can also get
an order of mozzarella sticks,
four, with marinara in there.
Applesauce.
Oh, yeah, breakfast.
Oh, good Lord.
All right. So, you get
pancakes and of course syrup.
And of course we're gonna do a syrup pour.
Wouldn't be a "Food Wars" episode
without me pouring
something on something else.
Oh, OK.
Ah!
[spits]
Ooh, yo!
You like that? You like
that how that looks?
Damn.
Ah, yes, the Croissan'wich.
So, as you can see,
what a Croissan'wich is,
is a breakfast sandwich where
a croissant is the buns.
How's it look?
Look good?
And also, similar to McDonald's,
breakfast sandwiches.
They also have breakfast biscuits,
also sausage, egg, and cheese.
And then last,
the US Burger King breakfast burrito.
Let's open it up. Let's
take a look inside!
What do they got there?
They got a egg, got sausage.
Oh, they got potato in here!
OK.
I wouldn't, I would not get
this, but good for them.
Good effort.
Last but not least,
you can also get yourself
a Hershey's sundae chocolate pie.
Oh, look at that. Look at that!
Oh, man, I just wanna jump into that.
Meaty.